adam is with us adam is going to be
where'd he go where'd he go where'd he
go there he is adams in texas hi adam
welcome to the dave ramsey show
how you doing dave i appreciate you
telling my call sure what's up
so i have a uh questions
slash motivation issue i
have over 180 thousand dollars of
student loans oh my god i have a small
doctor or a lawyer no i did get my
master's degree but it was in criminal
justice
and but i i worked for the military
and i'm about to retire um why did they
not pay for it
and because
most of the student loans are private
student loans and their
money does not pay for it i got my
college education prior to joining the
military
so you've had the 180 000 for years
i have okay well it's grown to be
about 180 thousand dollars wow
so currently i'm about to retire
from the military medical
and i'm working on trying to get another
job
prior to exiting out of the military
however
having difficulty finding the motivation
to get out of
the debt
i've i've discovered you and your
program about uh
this past december and found out a lot
of things that i did i did
incorrectly yeah so what is your career
plans
if everything went really good what
would you be doing
um if everything goes well i
would be working for customs
border patrol and i would have a
lot bigger shovel making what kind of
money
over a hundred thousand a year
wonderful okay well that's what we need
to scratch and claw and make happen then
because as you can obviously listen to
us because you're talking about the
size of your shovel versus the 180
thousand dollar hole that you're in
and that math gives you a lot more hope
and when you've got hope sometimes we
call that motivation
but i know part of that has to do with
my
medical issues whether or not i'll be
able to get that job
yeah well if you don't you've got to
find a plan b that sounds a lot like
that
because uh scratching and clawing and
working your way through this and
finding a way to keep you in get your
income going and get your income up at
least for a period of time
it may be working like a maniac to be
able to knock this out
because that's the only thing it's not
going away until you do that